The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi, I'm Sal.
Today we will be doing problem
number 4 of fall 2009, exam 1.
Now before you attempt the
problems there's certain
background information that
you should know before
attempting it.
One is knowledge in
ionic bonding.
Because the problem
deals with ions.
Two, how to draw an energy-level
diagram.
That's very important.
And three, what Madelung's
Constant is.
Now before attempting the
problem, it's a good thing to
read the whole problem in detail
and make sure you don't
skip anything out of it.
So that you get all
the information
that's given to you.
Because that's very important.
So the problem reads
as follows.
For a given cation, c and
anion a, show that the
following four energy
states on the same
energy-level diagram.
1, Ions in infinite
separation.
2, 9-pair c and a, c stands for
cation, a stands anion.
3, An ion line, c a c a c a,
just a repetitive line of
anions and cations.
And 4, crystalline
solid of c a.
So a three-dimensional crystal
structure with t and a.
And it says also that, assume
that the comparison is based
upon identical numbers of
ions in all four states.
The diagram need not to be drawn
to scale, however you
must convey relative values of
different energy states.
So that's the problem reads.
Now if you recall from lecture
there's an important equation
that actually describes the
energy between two ions,
between a cation and an anion.
And this energy is directly
proportional to the product of
the two charges.
And it's inversely proportional
to the separation
distance between them.
And it's multiplied
by some constants.
So what does this mean?
Well the fact that it's directly
proportional to the
product of your two charges
means that your energy for any
ion or anything that
ionically bonds,
it's going to be negative.
Because your z minus will be
negative and that's the whole
value of your energy
will be negative.
And that's what dictates
stability.
How negative the energy is.
So with that in mind,
we can go ahead
and start the problem.
So we have a cation
a and anion c.
Now I like to draw diagrams,
or draw little pictures
because that helps me when
I'm solving the problem.
So I'm just going to
draw pictures of a
cation and an anion.
So I have a cation, c and
then I have an anion, a.
So c and a, and the value of r
naught from our equation is
pretty much the separation
distance between the two.
So project this up,
this is r naught.
And if you look from the
picture, r naught is just
simply the radius of your
cation plus the
radius of your anion.
Now this is already describing
the energy between just a
cation and an anion with these
magnitude of charges.
So all that tells me is that,
this is already answering
number 2, pretty much from the
problem that we're asked for,
which is the ion pair.
So the problem asked you to draw
an energy-level diagram.
That's what I'm going
to do over here.
So I'm going to go ahead
and start drawing the
energy-level diagram.
Now I'm going to go ahead and
label my energy axis to be
positive to be up.
And I'm going to draw a
baseline of 0 here.
So I know that to be able to
incorporate my ion pair--
like I said the energy is
negative, so if the energy
goes up to here and let's say
the value of the energy here
is 0, then that ion pair should
lie somewhere below it.
So I'm going to go ahead
and draw this line.
And I'll label this, s 2 for
our energy level diagram.
So this is the ion pair.
Now number 1 says ions at
infinite separation.
What is the energy of two
charged species that are
separated by infinity?
Well if you look at your
equation, your equation tells
you that it's inversely
proportional to
the separation distance.
So all that tells you is that
if you divide by infinity,
your energy should
be essentially 0.
Which makes physical sense
because those two charged
species can't feel each other
when they're separated.
So this is actually already
my number 1, which is 0.
Separated away.
So now we need to find what the
energy is of an ion pair.
Which is the line of c a.
So we want to draw
a little picture.
It's pretty much going to
be a repetition of that.
And if I draw a line--
that's not very straight--
I'm going to draw a bunch
of cations and anions.
Essentially I can just imagine
that it extends to
infinity in both ways.
So with my energy between these
two ions right here is
given by my equation, then I
should be able to figure out
what the energy is of
the whole system.
Because we're talking about
electrostatic interaction,
which you can just
add linearly.
So I can make one assumption.
But look at my cation and anion
pair, I can go ahead and
simplify my life by letting
z plus be 1.
So I'll write that down.
I'll let z plus equal to
plus 1, which is the
charge on our cation.
And I'll let z minus equal minus
1, which is the charge
on the anion.
So that's to help
with the math.
So if I come back over here and
if I look at my equation
line then I know that
if I draw--
let's see-- a reference
access here.
Then the separation
between the cation
and anion is r naught.
And between the cation and
the other cation is
going to be 2 r naught.
And it's going to
extend for that.
So if I go ahead and relabel my
energy equation for a line.
I'll go ahead and call it e line
of function of r naught.
It's simply going to be the
first one, which is going to
be negative e squared over 4 pi
epsilon naught, r naught,
multiply the 1 over
minus 1 over n.
So that's the energy between
these two ions.
So now because the energy is
electrostatic, this cation
also feels the repulsion
of this other cation.
So therefore with that you
have got to add what that
interaction is.
So the product of the two
charges is plus 1, which gives
it a plus in front
of your equation.
And I end up getting e squared
over 4 pi epsilon naught.
Now here's something
that you should
pay particular attention.
The separation between these
two cation is not r naught.
It's actually 2 r naught.
Because of where exactly where
it sits on the line.
So my separation distance now
becomes 2 r naught and it's
multiplied by the same 1
minus 1 over n factor.
Then if you repeat it again,
you're analyzing the
interaction energy between the
cation and the other anion
that's next on the line.
So as you can see you end
up getting this nice--
4 pi epsilon naught, 3 r naught,
1 minus 1 over n.
And essentially it repeats
until it ends.
Now I'm just analyzing
on the right side.
Because it extends, it's an
infinite line, because it
extends from negative infinity
to infinity, then you can also
assume that there's an
anion to the left.
So all you really have to do
is, you take your overall
energy for the right side and
you multiply it by 2.
Because it's additive.
So this whole thing gets
multiplied by 2.
And that's essentially what
the energy is of a line.
Now in order to be able to
know where it lies on the
energy-level diagram, it's
important to try to get it
into the same basic form as
the energy of an ion pair,
just something simple
like over there.
So just by looking at the
equation I know there's a lot
of factors here that
are common.
Like that e squared, 4 pi
epsilon naught, even r naught
and this factor can all come
out of the equation.
You can take it out.
So if I do that, my equation of
my line then simply becomes
negative e squared over
4 pi epsilon naught.
Now I'm going to go ahead and
take out the r naught as well.
And I'm going to multiply
it by the factor.
And essentially what
stays from here is
just your 1 over 1.
From this one it's your 1/2
and then your 1/3 and then
we're happy.
And because I also took out the
negative, I want to make
sure that I take out the
negative from all
the other ones too.
So this product then gets
multiplied by 1 minus 1 over
2, plus 1/3 minus 1/4 plus...
and it goes on forever.
Now it so happens that this is
actually a series that we have
an answer or an answer to.
And this product that's being
multiplied by your fundamental
base of your equation
is just simply--
oh sorry I forgot the times 2,
don't forget that, that's very
important because you're summing
from both sides--
this essentially right here it's
simply arised because of
your geometry.
You're analyzing your systems.
And this value happens to be
greater than 1, which
is a good thing.
And the value of this
is actually 1.386.
So the fact that the whole
equation is still negative,
because we're talking about
coulombic interaction between
a negative charged species and
a positive charged species.
And we're multiplying that by a
value that is greater than 1
this means that if this is 1
right here, then our energy
level diagram should
lie somewhere below
it, like right here.
So this is 3.
And that's your ion line.
Now in real life we know
that crystals don't
exist in lines really.
Or they're not just an ion pair.
it's literally something
that is three-dimensional and
has an ordered structure.
Sometimes could be different
geometries, but normally it's
a cubic structure.
So because that forms in nature,
then that tells me
that the energy of a
three-dimensional crystal,
which is the fourth one that
we need to put on the
energy-level diagram,
the value should be
greater than 1.386.
And this value of 1.386 is
actually Madelung's Constant,
which you should know.
It was a required preliminary
to the problem.
So I know that below this
value of 1.386 I have my
three-dimensional crystal.
Now an energy-level diagram is
pretty much quantized by
different steps.
Now what is quantizing
our problem here?
Well this is 0 because
our energy is 0.
So we can almost assume that
we're multiplying--
or that the Madelung's Constant
for ion pair with
infinite separation is 0.
And this is 1, so we can assume
that the Madelung
Constant is 1 or we know that
it's 1 for the ion pair.
So if I start writing this out
on the side here-- give me
some space--
I know that's one.
I'm going to go ahead and
label this by Madelung's
Constant, which is 1.386.
So I come over here.
Relabel this.
This value here's is 1.386.
And this value here has to be
greater than 1.386 for a
three-dimensional crystal.
And this little diagram here is
the answer to your question
from the exam.
So when you take the exam you
don't really have to go
through all this math to
answer the problem.
If you know the material from
lecture, then the solution
should be very straight-forward
very easily.
And also if you keep in mind
that there's a lot of material
that you need to know before you
take the exam, and knowing
how to absorb that material and
apply it will help you in
solving these type of
problems, which
can be pretty difficult.